well I'd like to say good morning to
everybody and I want to thank everybody
on this
committee for getting their reports to
me I'm in there you know getting them in
and trying to get them to folks upstairs
but you're hanging in there and this an
exhausting process for everybody and
it's due to the number of bills which we
have and people are tired and but uh
this committee really needs to be
commended for what what you're
doing um I pardon
me back at you well we we we all are in
this we're in this together every one of
us um so what I want to do just quickly
here we are going to break for a caucus
um and uh because we're just executing
bills today uh I want to go down through
the bills which are on the dock at 4
today and although you know represent
Miler has a copy of this report um
we have some early bills which we are
going to be the the first bills which
we're going to have to address these
have to be out early as you know it and
so we're going to go down and take care
of
1402 if you want to check off in your
sheet uh but we have copies of all this
we can make available for you
1212 that deals with eligibility and and
free and reduced meals the 1402 deals
with uh
uh the proficiency exam waiver for
attendance at school
1678 is the New Hampshire Farm to school
local food
bill 1677 is participation in
efas um
1397 that's student placement by
achievement 1397 1397
1655 that's an
educator uh certification fund that's
1655 and 1419 obscene harmful materials
those are the seven early bills which we
have to wait through numbers the last
two numbers were
1655 and
1419 there are other bills on this list
you can see which are not early bills
but we are going to Wade through this a
number of the bills have been taken off
and will be placed on the docket for
next
week uh however here's uh the bills
which are up that we will be discussing
in the caucuses as well 1216 is the
cross District bullying
Bill we're doing that next week no that
these are this today these are
today then we're going to be doing
1516 deals with District employees that
children enrolling in the school where
the district employee works so it's
1516 we will also go back and deal with
1109 1109 which is the ID cards for
eating
disorders
1652 is an EFA it's a local EFA
Bill uh so we will deal with that
uh 1691 which is the definition for an
adequate education
adequacy
1639 children at uh State
facilities another powerful bill that
you know we got to get a handle on and
as as the replacement stuff the costs
especially
1480 alternative dispute resolution at
1524 parents observing special ed cost
rooms
1524 1469 is IEP records
1695 student identifiable information
and that's it for there's 11 bills there
totaling a total of 18 bills which we
could possibly look at we looked at 19
yesterday
1476 in 1476 yes corre it's I didn't
read it Charter that's theou of the
charter
schools so that makes a total of 18
bills so what we want to do is for the
public knowing that we're not going to
be doing some of the other bills which
weren't mentioned so you don't wait have
to wait here and thinking you're going
to have that um so there's no higher
education bills being discussed
today um so what we'll do is we'll break
into caucus and
um each caucus look at these bills and
then we'll come back and we'll try to
find where there's any common ground
or me yeah we'll do that afterwards yeah
yeah yeah I think that's probably more
appropriate that you have a chance so
right now we are going to go in a
caucus um it this would I expect this
will take a little bit of time seeing
that we haven't had really you know some
groups probably haven't looked at some
of these bills um so um I would say it's
going to be at least a 20 minute caucus
probably right to about
10:30 maybe even longer who
knows so let's get on
it Bel could you sign up afterno after
no we're not we're not and you're not
meeting at Friday either what we're
trying to do is people need a
break
okay um pardon
me yeah I do um some later well I tell
you right now on February the 5th that's
Monday we have hearings 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
eight
hearings first one is 1185 that's sexual
educator education
instruction okay so we we we will be
meeting uh starting at 9:30 in the
morning in the last bill scheduled for
3:00 on on February the 6th we'll be
starting at 9:30 these are all hearings
there's no exact there uh we start at
9:30 and the last bill is set up for uh
no no exacts on February 7th we're
exacting on next next
Wednesday and we're starting at
9:30 and we'll get out when we get
out
yeah
okay thank
you
yes the subcommittee
for for funding is on
Friday that's on Friday yet scheduled
for
10:00 I will be putting a sub committee
together for the other two bills due
process and freedom of speech that's
going to be on February the
12th we are meeting on the 12th so I'm
just work it in so people don't have to
travel twice or
[Music]
stay
okay
okay I think I think we're ready to go
here uh
just for everybody um there's going to
be a number of bills today which we're
going to end up with no recommendation
that's the route we're going to go so
what we've agreed upon uh between
representative Miler and myself is that
when we're at one of those bills where
you know the the person that's you know
made the motion will be able to speak
but beyond that we that's it we want to
get these things done so because we know
we're going to come out with a
1010 we know that so because we have
these early bills we need to get them so
we can get down into the bottom part of
this list as well so the first bill
which we want to to um
address is the
1655 it's an early Bill educator
certification fund
that's okay I recognize uh representa
cordelli for a
motion uh thank you Mr chairman I'd like
to move out to pass on House Bill
1655 is there a second on
1655 I'll second it so we have a motion
made by representative cordelli and
second by representative luno the motion
is ought to pass representa cordelli or
represent either one of you want to
speak on this I'll pass just real quick
CH I I I I think this is a housekeeping
um sort of Bill I don't think it's
caused a problem in the past but I don't
think the change will cause a cause a
problem either so I think it's probably
also another bill that shouldn't have
come to this
committee okay so with that uh we're
ready any further discussion from
anybody here ready to go on it so we're
ready when you are represent cordel
cordal Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell not here not here
okay representative cor kilo yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative B
Bon it yes uh representative cascaden
yes representative Damon yes chairman
lad yes 19 y one absent
consent we are going to take a
break I don't know where she went she
went
for the eating disord that was
brutal so we can
Mo yeah we could do that I'll just step
out okay well I I'll get him back in
here then you were GNA hold the
committee waiting for yeah we are just
because we know what the verdict is
going to be
yeah okay this bill we're going to be uh
jumping down doing 16 1677 that's
participation it's an EFA bill that's we
got an amendment coming we got an
amendment on that one too 1677 yes and
we have
25% okay
so no we're not we're not doing it we're
not doing
it we have too many amendments coming at
the last moment here um
let's go to the um
122 yeah you have a pending motion on
that yeah what is the pending motion
because I don't have a sheet I'm I'm I'm
starting from scratch I just started
from scratch so the pending motion was
itl and moved by who who made the mo
pending motion on the this is
eligibility for beler Bel
okay so you made the penny Mo so belch
has made that motion was there a second
to that I was I don't know who it was
though yeah I don't I don't know where
the sheet
went
yeah
okay thank you
okay so right now we we have a motion on
the floor itl made by previously by
represent beler and second by represent
Cordell
um represent belshire do you want to
speak to that or or leave it where we
are I think we know which way it's going
to go so I suppose I'll just wait to
speak on the floor okay
so nobody else here okay Madam clerk
would you please call the role on
the on on the on the uh itl
motion chairman cordelli
yes representative leus yes
representative
Ford
no representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative p uh oh okay she's not
here representative cor yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner
no
represent sorry representative Luna is
not here no he's AB uh representative
Heath no Representative wock
no representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
so that is 8 y 10 NS two absent
okay is there a subsequent motion
represent
Miler is there a second
second hand up okay okay represent Miler
made the motion and it's second by
represent
Hall further
discussion repent Hall thank you um
hb212 increases the eligib ility for
free School meals for our most vul
vulnerable student population it's
designed to help support low to Middle
income families who are struggling to
make ends meet this bill is similar to
last year's bipartisan bill which passed
this committee on a 12 to8 vote the Full
House on 2011 to 177 vote the primary
difference is the increase in the
eligibility cap from 300 to
350% will it cost 34 million 50 million
maybe even 75 million I don't know but
our job on this education committee is
to consider matters which address the
educational needs of students it's a
duty of the committee of Finance to
examine and consider appropriations of
State money as we know School meals play
a critical role in the health well-being
and academic success of students we
received testimony from New Hampshire
hunger solutions that over half of New
Hampshire children reportedly live in
households with insufficient
food this bill is an effort to alleviate
food food insecurity and poverty and to
support good nutrition School meals are
as essential as buses books computers
last year we heard from a former
superintendent that the most difficult
part of his job was calling off school
knowing that students might not eat that
day that was heartbreaking our
neighboring states of Vermont Maine and
Massachusetts all have passed permanent
Universal meals
legislation House Bill 1212 is an
investment in New Hampshire future it's
not only the right thing to do it's the
least we can do I hope you will join me
in voting
OTP thank you okay um represent B thank
you Mr chair I guess I'll give a a brief
talk on this one um so hb212 so what the
bill does is it proposes to ra raise the
eligibility threshold for free School
meals from the current 185% of poverty
level to 350 uh% of poverty level um and
it would allocate New Hampshire taxpayer
funds to cover that difference as no
federal reimbursement would be available
for um the program proposed here uh the
community did receive competing fiscal
analyses of this bill though what is
entirely clear out of these analyses is
that the minimum cost that we've seen
would be approximately $50 million per
year more realistic appeared to be the
100 million figure but depending on
whether schools are doing breakfast and
lunch it is conceivable that the actual
final amount could double
that critically important to this
proposal is that despite we are looking
to expend New Hampshire taxpayer funds
solely on this program we the New
Hampshire taxpayers and us as their
representatives would have virtually no
Senator pel you can't come in here right
now we would have virtually no control
over the expenditure of these funds
because we are essentially using them to
expand an existing Federal progam
program so all of the current federal
guidelines would continue to apply
including as we've heard uh guidelines
that have bidding requirements that
don't allow us to purchase local
nutritious Foods because they don't come
in low enough in the bidding it would
require USDA nutritional guidelines
which at this point are very highly
contested for their extreme um emphasis
on carbohydrate load uh and to which the
program has demonstrated approximately
30 % waste because of per studies what
the studies say is that there's an
inherent lack of emphasis on
palatability and desirability of the
food under USDA guidelines uh finally
just to just to clarify a point between
between food and security and um food
insufficiency we did receive testimony
that a large very large percentage of
New Hampshire students are food
insecure I delved into the dumbers a
little bit and specifically the question
asked in order to determine whether
their food insufficient
is do you have enough of the specific
food that you want to
eat in order to eat that now given the
way that question is worded I'm food
insufficient because I'd like to have a
ribeye every single night toss are up I
might get one a month if I'm lucky but
actually looking at Food
insufficiency which would be the other
category we were not provided numbers
for that but they would undoubtedly be
significantly lower and I would like to
see some actual numbers regarding food
uh insufficiency not merely insecurity
if we are to expend these kinds of funds
thank you we're in the middle of a
vote okay um not seeing any further
hands for this uh Madam Kirk would you
please call the rooll vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative
Ford
no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative p uh not here repes
representative Corel no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative
Tanner yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative bbon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
no n y
n t yes on
this so the vote is what then Madam perk
so then I'll fix that all and it would
be 10
8 to absent okay thank you very much so
the motion
passes and what we're going to do is
we're just going to take a break right
now we're gonna have I just ask a a
Minority
Report
yes okay thank you we're gonna take a
break have lunch right now we gonna and
then we'll come
back at uh well I want to come back a
little how about about quarter quarter
one
4ic
again and and there will be a caucus in
this room immediately following our
right
now
for
Republicans 1245 seem to do
this we're having it right now
okay
e
hey let's uh begin the afternoon session
chairman lad is still working on some
reports so we'll start with a a
discussion of um one bill at least um
let's start with um House Bill 16 uh 78
the New Hampshire Farm to
school
Bill and representative beler do you
have an a
motion uh thank you Mr chair I would
move um ought to pass on the farm the
school
bill is there a
second okay represent
[Music]
Damon I saw your hand
so
Damon
okay further discussion and an amendment
yes thank you Mr chair I would like to
introduce Amendment
H uh this
amendment sure
yep do we have a second representative
lakas uh does everyone have the uh
Amendment it went around during launch I
passed it
381 okay please proceed thank you um so
this makes a number of changes that were
I believe NE necessary to this bill to
make it function and proper uh without
changing the underlying intent of the
bill and what it actually is seeking to
accomplish um so we retain the concept
of a farm to school program that is
going to be funded uh as a pilot program
out of state
coffers and let's go through the changes
I've made from the original bill first
um under item two I have modified the
committee to be in ACC EXC me item two
you referring to Roman 2 yes okay
apologies uh I have modified the
committee to be the makeup that was
recommended uh in testimony from from uh
some of the experts we heard
from in
Roman yeah so that that was lines 12 and
in
the bill or in the
amendment in the
amendment uh
yes is included a farmer or farmer
representative and also an expert on
Child
Nutrition
notic
that okay go ahead representative thank
you uh in Roman 3 I have struck part of
the last sentence um which would have
allowed for the purchase of of kitchen
equipment or storage equipment um I
believe this should be really designed
to help the farmers and purchase food
not not equipment which could eat up a
lot of the funds very
quickly the Roman four I have struck New
England um to limit the program to New
Hampshire uh simply because I cannot
justify uh using New Hampshire taxpayer
funds to subsidize out ofate
farms in Roman 6 this is uh actually
let's go back to five Roman five the
last sentence excluding uh fluid
milk was
struck Roman six all all of Roman six
was struck and this was uh of critical
importance because as the bill was
originally written we've heard testimony
from multiple people that the bill um
the current reason that they can't
purchase uh New Hampshire products in a
significant quantity is because the USDA
free lunch program bidding requirements
are uh prohibitive because New Hampshire
Farmers simply can't get their costs
down enough to be able to sell it uh at
profit
um so in order to actually make this
program work we have to eliminate the
references to USDA program and put this
program into the state hands instead of
the federal
program in Roman
7 um changes were made to reflect that
this is a New Hampshire program not um
New England
wide I've also modified uh the language
regarding what happens with retained
funds or excess funds because it was
unclear in the original bill now
um the uh unspent funds will be
reallocated um between schools within
the private program after the first year
to be expended in the manner prescribed
herein during year two of the pilot
program uh and the last sentence in
Roman
7 uh there there was an addition to the
end uh to say that at the end of the
pilot program I'm assuming that this is
not re repped um any unused funds would
become part of the state general
fund Roman
nine uh modifications have been made to
add a couple criteria to help us track
uh the performance of this program and
some metrics and to also allow the U
committee that is formed or commission
committee whatever it's labeled as um to
add metrics as they fit for tracking
purposes
struck yeah excuse me I think in the
original Bill Roman 6 in the original
bill was removed right yes so this is a
new 7 8 and N excuse me 67 and eight in
the amendment correct so it's been
relabeled to I apologize I was referring
to the original bill now it's become
Roman 8 not
nine
and that appears to be it for for
changes to this bill I'd be happy to
take questions if anybody has
any no thank
you
thank you um so I don't see in the
amendment if I'm correct that this is
essentially replacing language there's
no appropriation in the
amendment represent what in the original
bill is page two lines 22 to 27 that's
the exact same problem we had with the
other bill that we're trying to amend so
that
now no sorry right so um if you look on
the original Bill line 22 that stays
because the um Amendment just says
inserted by section one so section two
doesn't change on from the original Bill
correct thank you for the clarification
may I continue with other questions
followup thank
you
um h on
I would appreciate some clearer language
on what an expert in childhood nutrition
is and would suggest that it's say a
registered dietitian with pediatric
expertise I guess that's not a qu would
you entertain that now it's a question I
I appreciate it but I think at this late
stage it's going to be too late to try
to get another amendment on this bill so
I I would prefer to leave it as
[Music]
is
representative M thank you Mr chair and
representative belger for bringing this
forward I think you made some excellent
changes I just have a question to
clarify line six of your Amendment says
that the money could be purchas used to
purchase from New Hampshire and New
England P um producers but then if you
go on to line 26 and other places in the
bill it says Foods purchased under the
program shall originate in New Hampshire
so my question is is it New Hampshire or
is it New Hampshire and the rest of New
England thank you and and yes that is a
very good question um line six that was
an oversight on my part that was an
error to not remove New England
producers however in terms of the effect
of the law what we're seeing in line one
is simply a description it does not
actually affect the execution of the law
which is clear to New Hampshire I would
hope that the Senate would be able to
just take out New
England represent Miler thank you Mr
chair when we had this bill before one
one of the questions that was raised by
chairman lad was the issue I think he
was talking about a large Dairy Farm in
Vermont that did a lot of business in
New
Hampshire but based upon this
language would that would exclude that
purchase of whatever it might be whether
it be beef or whatever from a Vermont
producer is that correct correct it
would have to be an origin New Hampshire
product to qualify this okay thank
you represent Damon thank you Mr chair
yes I have more um relative to
the um effort to remove New England
producers New Hampshire has a lot of
farms on the
borders of our intersecting
States as a represent resentative for
Sullivan County Claremont the only
distinction between Claremont and
Vermont geographically speaking is the
cantica river I know of at least one
school district in my representative
district that their food service is run
by a Vermont owned company and they buy
from Vermont and New Hampshire
Farms I don't think the removing New
England prohibition makes sense it it's
functionally
difficult
let me kick in on that a little bit here
we're talking about the Connecticut
River of course we own the Connecticut
River their land starts on the other
side of it
um so but uh we do have some Interstate
school districts as well and I've talked
about Fairley Vermont uh and Orford
being linked together Fairley and
Corinth and some of those towns and my
community also our transportation for
buses is all from it it's all working
cooperatively with Blue Mountain across
the river from us which is in uh
Bradford Vermont and Newberry Vermont
and Wells River so and we also are
purchasing food for the schools from
Four Corners Farm in Newberry and it's
all considered local and I've mentioned
before that local control up in our neck
of the woods is any Town that's AB
budding or within a certain radius of
our particular community so the fact
that we're going to eliminate being able
to do this business with folks with
Farms that I can stand on my deck and
look at them across the river um it it
it makes it more
difficult thank
you R
lakas I just wanted to point
out or remind people this this is just a
pilot
program and it's only one District Per
County and so it doesn't have to take at
this this at this point in time all of
the little ins and outs and across the
rivers and this Dairy fireman whatever
into consideration it's just a pilot
program which can then when it if it
becomes a full program if we decide it's
worthwhile then we can add all of those
other states and other town and make
sure and deal with schools on the river
and that kind of
stuff than you
yes represent Miler thank you Mr chair
uh represent belter could you could you
talk about the
elimination of uh section six again on
why that is being I know you said it
earlier but this is new to me so can you
explain it again please absolutely yes
uh so the original section six reads all
food purchase through the program shall
comply with National School lunch
program and federal Child Nutrition
program guidelines now those guidelines
that are being referenced are already in
place in our USDA free lunch program we
heard testimony from multiple experts
from UNH and elsewhere that currently
there it is it is cost prohibitive to be
able to purchase from local in New
Hampshire farms in our current USDA free
lunch program Because the bidding
process is such it's mandated by the
federal government this bidding process
simply does not allow New Hampshire
Farmers to come in as one of the
cheapest options to allow for that
purchase to happen as such that was a
critical flaw in this bill that even if
we pass the original bill as is we could
make the appropriation for the money but
that money would just have to sit there
because it wouldn't be able to be
expended because New Hampshire Farmers
can't come in under that bidding process
as it is so it had to be removed to make
it
workable further
questions okay what was
the the on the amendment so we haven't
voted on the Amendment yeah
okay are there any further questions on
the amendment so uh we have before us
Amendment 0381 H Madam clerk would you
please call the
RO
represent
yes
yeah then would I
be I would promote some amendments to
the amendment there are parts of the
amendment that I think are improvements
and parts that I see as problematic I
wondering about the process in terms of
our
timeline the timeline does allow for us
to do some amending but it's
narrow uh we will be meeting again next
week and then according to the schedule
which I hand out will be executing bills
on the 7th of February and then again on
on the 13th of February
uh we have several bills that are going
to come up on the or one more bill which
will be there on the on the 13th or the
12th excuse me but we have we have
already early bills on schedule for the
7th 1 2 3 4 five so it could be added on
to that but amendments would have to be
done by the by this hopefully by the six
so we could see them
may I yes so given that I would like to
know
um the sponsor of the amendment and the
committee in
general I don't think that putting fluid
milk back in the bill makes sense milk
is one of the most affordable things
that school districts Buy and they
mostly buy locally so it shouldn't be
part of this
process um I think it's great to take
out equipment but we need to put New
England back in my
opinion repr Bel if I may just on on the
milk one I'm not married to the concept
but I I don't love the idea of excluding
our milk or Dairy Farmers because this
is as much to help the Farms as is the
schools on the New England thing I I
could not support this bill with New
England May I respond yes could you
support it if it gave a
mileage you know 25 50 miles from New
Hampshire
borders I appreciate the the question
but I I too live right on the border
literally I I look right in the main and
I have all these Farms right there and I
enjoy frequenting them but I I cannot
bring myself to to spend taxpayer New
Hampshire taxpayer funds subsidizing an
out ofate
Farm further
discussion me okay we're going to break
for
caucus
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative peternell yes
representative corello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
albon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 20a z n okay we have the bill in
front of us as to be uh let's see uh we
have a motion I came who made that
motion in the beginning was V okay
representative and and representative
Damon okay so now representative beler
you need topa right otpa we need a new
motion we're otpa I believe um and I
don't think I need to speak too much
more on this thank
you are you a second on that okay is
there for further discussion on this
bill okay m
s Vice chairman cordelli
no representative leus
yes representative Ford no
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon
yes chairman lad
no 177 Ys three
Nays okay who's
consent
consent next
bill before I what's the that 167
we're going to go ahead now and
do what 13 1397 the student placement uh
achievement
1397 who was supposed to make the motion
did you guys discuss it no we just got
the amendment
and okay
uh
yes I represent LE you recognize for uh
a
motion I would like to move
OTP is there a
second
second okay we have a motion made by
represent leus second by represent
cordelli representa leus would you like
to speak to your
motion I would Al whoops I would also
like to introduce an amendment but um I
believe representative cordelli has that
I don't know what the number is it's uh
0390 should be coming around
okay
[Applause]
did
do okay now I would like to introduce
Amendment um 2024
d39h and what this there a second okay
sorry
me thank
you we have a motion on the floor we
need to have a
second second represent cordelli
second go
ahead what the amendment basically does
is just applies it to 7th through 12th
grade
further
discussion Is there further discussion
on the amendment um this doesn't it
doesn't change anything in law that's
currently there all it says is the
what's what's already there is to be
published in the student handbook to be
available to students and parents that's
really all this bill
does
I know people are reading the amendment
so I'll give a few moments
here represent Hall do you have a
question do we think it's in handbooks
right now do you think or you think no
and that's the problem no ever it's not
well I won't I don't know it's in every
single handbook in every single school
but I would say no it's not and that's
why people don't know about it because
you know it's in law but how many people
know what all of our laws are so this
just makes students aware of
it further discussion yes represent
cascaden um thank you Mr chair I just
want to point out that there are
policies that address this already on
the books um they are policy IFA
instructional needs for each individual
student and cjg which is the assignment
of students to classes and grade levels
that both of those give flexibility to
the intent of this bill so it
exists further discussion represent
Woodcock thank you chman just a question
on the amendment I notice that in the
amendment in line six added child School
excuse me line five added child schools
yet when we get down further into lines
uh 10 it just talks about local school
districts which child schools and local
school districts aren't the
same governments correct that's
correct
okay it's it's an eror chair yes so a
question to the chair um the the the
bill and the
amendment seem both both directed to
courses that are placement and courses
that are offered by the high
school am I correct in that uh 7 through
12 7 through 12 7 yeah that that thank
you um yet 193 C12 seems to be directed
at the Statewide
assessment I don't have my book with me
do you have a do you have a book going
to go get my okay I I'm
just I'm it just doesn't seem to
read I'm looking at page
552 that's a different one that's
that is um um
1402 this is so I don't know
what that's that's what I'm
saying I don't think that's what this is
about Place
15 take another
course oh sure yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
espe
yeah it appears that this is in the area
of improvement and
assessment
so my question to the committee is this
bill
ready I don't think
so I can see how the author
has taken out the Elementary grades
which I think is a good thing to
do but there's been two points mentioned
here one the section law is put into and
on line 10 leaving out or Charter Public
Schools so represent can I just ask the
author of the bill
intent is it your intent um with this
bill that when a when it is believed
that the student has accomplished all
the necessary competencies for that
cours workk that the student should be
eligible to move on when ready so you
are you looking at a
determination of um competency the only
thing the only thing that bill was
supposed to do was make for all schools
including Elementary grades whatever
that school's policies are to just print
them in the school clearly the student
manual that was all this was supposed to
do it blew up into this huge thing about
how to assess and whether you can assess
in elementary schools and all of this
stuff it had nothing to do with that
because as c as rep c hadn't said that
stuff has already exists the only thing
this bill was supposed to do was say put
it in the student handbook whatever it
is whatever the school has just put it
in the student handbook that's it it
didn't get written up quite like I
wanted to begin with this we were trying
to at any rate it was supposed to be a
very simple bill it was a few lines that
I submitted to ol it turned into a big
argument about things that this doesn't
even
cover question yes when you say print it
in the school manual some schools don't
even print them they just have it online
so that's fine if it were online and
there was a policy as representative T
mentioned so in the school manual that's
online it just puts a link to it do they
have to print the whole thing out or
just a link that's already so it's
already published so the idea is so that
a student or a parent can know what the
policies are that's that's it but
they're already published well they're
not
they're publish I don't mean like
printed but yes if the school has them
if the school H yes just put them where
they're in the what would be the
equivalent of the school
handbook because most schools don't
print handb well
that's on on online where there is a
section that is that students and
parents are supposed to read right which
is the student handbook which might be
online
only just put it there so it can be
found by students and parents that's
that's it
that's is there any more discussion on
this
bill we have yes represent Cas Ken uh
just want to add that these policies are
already on student
websites
they're already
public anyway they're already there
representative
McDonald I guess then I have a question
for you representative cascaden do we
know that it's on every school's
handbook and would this bill allow it to
be on every school
handbook I can't vouch for all the
schools so further discussion yeah I
know what you're cordel you had your
hand up uh just uh I know um it's been
said that this is in policies I'm not
sure if it's in every school district's
policies um I know the school boards
Association maybe has a a sample policy
to that regard but I I don't know what
that means um and I know looking at my
district trying to go through and find
policies is not the easiest thing in the
world further discussion on the
amendment would you please call the role
madam cler
Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Heath no Representative wock no
representative Hall no represent
resentative bon no Representative
cascaden no and representative
Damon chairman lad yes 10 y 10 so the
amendment
fails we're back to the main motion
now want to pass on the bill
itself any further
discussion can I ask a question yes
would people will be willing to let me
fix this amendment and come back next
week or
not I don't see any hands
up rep and
dry have a place do you have a place
where you thought this would go that's
different okay thank you
okay any further
discussion now we're talking
about back to the original Bill and now
we're talking about the primary grades
too any further
discussion mam clerk would you please
call the
Vice chairman cordelli no Representative
leus no representative
Ford no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no Representative
corello no representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
tenner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no representative w
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad no
zero y 20
Nays so is there a subsequent motion
here is that
second who said that down
repres okay the motion was made by Miler
second by
luno uh represent a Myer do you have
anything further to
say represent luno no further
discussion
okay Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford
no represent Belcher yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative celo yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 y One
n yeah no problem with consent
ask I like the way you make these
motions and they have already write them
up for you I got to figure that
out okay so we're on to the next
bill 1302 waiting on Amendment and 1419
we're waiting on Amendment so what we
got all the bottom
ones what about um
well there Amendment there Amendment
there Amendment there Amendment there
yeah by early bills
okay yeah yeah okay all for
amendments um this one we have a split
in amongst the caucus on this one
there's
a
Bel Amendment but we're split on the
amendment OTP
how come we're getting all these late
amendments yeah
156 um I think we have the amend for
that so we can go
ahead we are looking
for Amendment Amendment Amendment
Amendment
Amendment we have the amendment these
are the only two we're waiting
amendments are 1109 and 1652 too okay
okay okay I'm going to ask those people
are requesting
amendments okay we need to get these
amendments hustling
along all right so we're going to go
right to um
we go
uh how about 1524 parents observing
special
education dry you recognize for a
motion 15
1524 all
right
you ready yes go well yeah go ahead okay
I make a motion of a to pass is there a
second
second okay represent cor cornelli made
the second and repres dry made the
motion represent
dry uh in looking at the
this the uh handouts that we got from
people who testified in favor of of this
bill um one that stood out was from the
state advisory committee on the
education of children students with
disabilities and they talked about um
they support this bill provided it's
amended to remove the part that says
School District shall impose no
conditions or restrictions um and then
they went on to talk about safety
concerns and things like that when we
looked at the the statement in the bill
it says that they will impose no
conditions or restrictions except those
necessary to ensure the safety of
children in the program so we feel that
the the comments that they made here
that were concerns were actually
addressed if you read the entire
sentence of the bill in in the bill
that's submitted and so um we are voting
uh odd to
pass further
discussion from the
committee okay uh not seeing any hands
up mam clerk will you please call the
rule chman cordelli yes representative
leus yes representative Ford yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative Luna no representative
Heat no Representative wock no
representative Hall no Representative
albon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
10 y 10 y surprise
surprise okay so is there a subsequent
motion move represent Miler moves itl is
had a
second okay second comes from represent
luno represent miler please vote please
vote I love your
discussion best speech
ever well further
discussion not seeing any thank you very
much motion is itl on
1524 Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Ford no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no representative
Coro no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative W yes representative Hall
yes representative
Alon sorry Al is yes yes represent
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10
n r
Alon it turned on when it finally when
you gave up
okay you want to
support put forth the motion if you want
yeah I'll move
it is there a second on that
second further
discussion not seeing
any Madam
cler chairman Vice chairman
cordelli
no Representative
leus
no representative Ford no representative
Belcher no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no Representative corello no
representative
Miler yes yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
no 10 y 10 days okay so we know where we
are
that yeah yeah and cascad doing the
report okay
good
okay which one of the ones the
amendments are coming back on now um I
just am sending them to copy um 1552 and
1419 up top here okay oh so they haven't
printed them yet no they're yeah they're
in copying
yeah okay let's do um
1216 cross District
bullying
yeah we
do I'll head up there thanks yeah thank
you 12 16
buing
okay okay we need some it's going
support the
OTP just
Bel or I don't know several people
support the OTP yeah I'll support the
OTP not the not the amendment well make
the motion for the OTP then uh Mr
chairman I would like to move uh OTP on
hb1 1216 I'll second
it represent
cordelli um I think cross District
bullying is an important topic we heard
uh quite a bit of testimony about um a
particular case um and the fact that uh
District um would not investigate
because it was not in statute um so I
think it's incumbent that we make sure
it is in statute and that uh districts
know that U the uh resident district for
the bully needs to do the investigation
um buling is such an important topic uh
we shouldn't let this um a slip by
us and uh I'll I'll speak to as ER II uh
we did have communication on this from
uh a professor up in North Country
dealing with that particular situation I
don't need to name the name of the
school districts but absolutely saying
we need to do something with the bill as
it was submitted to us and recommend
highly recommended ought to pass because
there has been a significant issue with
the bullying going across districts and
impacting uh the life of of a student in
one of those schools significantly so I
I think this bill is needed as it was
presented represent
Miler there's no doubt that this is an
awful thing to happen to a student and
it needs to be addressed
however during the testimony there were
several questions
raised um about dealing with Independent
Schools dealing with students uh from
outside the state I and if you had a
bullying situation ation for a student
for example in
Ohio uh what's the jurisdiction as it
relates to dealing with that so although
this is a very important issue and I
totally agree with the intent of the
motion I think there are some issues
that were uncovered during the testimony
that need further look before we
actually place this in uh to statutes so
I will be voting against the OTP and if
the OTP fails I will then put a motion
for inim study on this so we can have a
broader look at the legal implications
and who's responsible Etc thank you
representative
Belcher thank you Mr chair I um I I
previously brought some of this up but I
had some very uh steep concerns over
part of existing law here that this
amends in part one uh rather Roman One
Part B and I have drafted an amendment M
I would like to introduce at this time
uh Amendment 2024
02558 uh the committee should have
received this last week I
believe I'll give you a moment before
proceeding I would move uh a to pass on
this amendment is there a second on the
amendment that uh represent beler is
proposing thank you so uh represent
beler would like to speak further on
your Amendment yes thank you Mr chair so
um if you look at the current language
here in Roman one uh Item B the first
sentence occurs off of school property
or outside of a school sponsored event
uh or activity so this is not a school
related event the second sentence then
goes on to if the conduct interferes
with a people people's educational
opportunities and subst or substantially
disrupts the orderly operations of the
school or School sponsored activity or
event um so that language in the second
sentence is derived um quite closely
from the language of a Supreme Court
decision in the in the case of Tinker um
which is a several multiple decades old
predent the trouble is that there was
another Supreme Court president in
2021 that took another look at this
issue and further clarified this and
they specifically said that the decision
in Tinker from which that language is
derived only applies to circumstances
happening in school or at a school event
as such the language as currently
existing in law is already not in
compliance with this Supreme Court
decision is therefore I believe
unconstitutional when we go on to add
cross distric to it we actually exceed
that a little bit further so what I have
done is I have redrafted Item B in this
bill and that's the only thing that
changes is Item B for out of school and
out of school event activities and I
have imported the entire piece of
language from the Supreme Court decision
in 2021 that outlines the specific
circumstances in which a school is
authorized to regulate off-campus speech
of students so I would ask that you
support this amendment thank
you further discussion
repr McDonald thank you Mr chair and
with the utmost respect for my colleague
who brought this amendment forward I
personally will not be supporting this
amendment I do not like on line four
specifically where it says constitutes
serious or severe bullying I think the
inclusion of those words will leave
students left behind and who defines if
bullying is serious or severe that seems
a bit vague in its language so I will
not be supporting this amendment because
the bill as presented is strongest and I
would encourage you to vote for the bill
as introduced to us thank you representa
cascaden um I agree uh to a certain
extent with representative beler that
Tinker versus de Mo um that would
violate um the First Amendment however
the amendment I'm not sure
does what was intended
either um I think what needs to be
thought through is that schools don't
have investigative officers on staff
they have a process of questioning that
they can bring a student in
independently question them and then
form a decision on whether yes there's
been bullying or no there hasn't been
bullying and that works okay when you
have two New Hampshire superintendant
that can
collaborate but you don't always have
that and what happens on the internet
interet how I mean you could I could
just think you spend a whole week
investigating a case from somebody from
another state who keeps sending
something to say three or four students
in a public school obviously causing A
disruption at that point and I think it
has to become a police
matter because schools are not
detectives do I think cyber bullying and
bullying is a problem
yes and how can we develop a
bill for New Hampshire schools I really
don't care about other states but I care
about our kids to protect our kids from
these incidents and I think we need to
be careful about that there's a furer
violation any school you
call if it's not one of your
colleagues you know if you say hey is so
and so a student
there they better say no or I can't
disclose that because they
can't and how do they know who's calling
them is not somebody just
calling um you just can't be trusting of
that but I would like to see something
in paper that does allow New Hampshire
superintendent to collaborate on such
situations that occur that are causing A
disruption in their schools and that's
why I think we need a little bit of time
for an Norm
study further
discussion on the
bill am on the on the on the
amendment okay I I don't understand
thank you failure to follow rules
concerning lessons I
if I may address that so I I didn't want
to pretend that I was capable of
conceiving of all possible circumstances
in which bullying could occur so I
simply took the entirety of the language
outlined um and by the way this Supreme
Court decision was not narrow it was an
8:1 decision with the majority opinion
by uh justice Brier um and this was his
language that I pulled directly from the
opinion further
discussion from the committee
I do have a question for um those that
have been in the business here of
administration in the state
um there was a situation in the North
Country
SAU and were both those superintendant
talking with you just made mention it
it'll work where you know for example we
always have a great relationship where
we are with with Plymouth and
Woodsville um is there such an
arrangement up there and how come it
went as far as it had to go all the way
down to
conquer because the media only published
half the story I I have I have spoken to
both of those superintendent yeah uhuh
and it had been resolved the bully was
disciplined and the student apparently
wasn't that was being
bullied um was in the district only for
a few
months um sad case yeah but they did
work together and they did work through
it Mr
yes if my
rection
my thoughts are right when they
presented when it that question was
asked and the answer was that the
parents did want did not want to go to
the police um and they wanted that's why
they pressured the schools to resolve
the issue um and it was because they
were uh didn't have uh full
um full power of English language and
they they were feeling as though they
would be discriminated against if they'd
gone to the police I think that was what
my re recollection is of their
testimony so my followup to all this is
that why then did the attorney to the
district advise not to go for for with
this anybody have an answer
it's assess in the letter right here
that we got from this individual now
this is a person that's an elderly
person that's also I guess a professor
up that way at the sau's attorney's
Direction the principal superintendent
and School District's board chair
refused to address the bullying by their
student Mr chair if I may I I I would
believe that was likely a matter of
liability yeah it could be that but
they're looking at the Safety and
Security of a student I would think that
it could go the other way
too
so represent cordelli uh thank you um I
I cannot support the amendment for a
couple of reasons um some of which
follows on to representative McDonald um
first I think this changes the def of
bullying in the
statute
secondly
um I see where part of this is taken
from um the attachment of a course I
don't know if that was direct ruling or
um not but the last part or any speech
not normally protected by First
Amendment standards I don't see in the
attachment of the Court decision so I
don't know where that came from so it
was not pulled from um the court
decision as far as I can
see further discussion represent
beler sorry if I if I may respond to the
that part that indeed was pulled from
the uh Supreme Court opinion it may have
it may not have been on the particular
page I provided but it was it was
highlighted in a separate part also by
Justice Brier about um a possible route
to or Nexus to local schools that might
implicate their regulatory interests in
free
speech
further discussion from the
committee okay let's have a a vote on
the uh Amendment
please Vice chairman cordelli no
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald no representative Noble yes
Representative
peternell
no representative Coro
yes representative Miler
no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
luno representative Heath no
representative WKA no representative
Hall
no representative Balon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no uh chairman lad
no uh so six y 14
days okay we're back to the main motion
which is ought to pass on the bill any
further discussion on the
bill representative
petno this um particular bill has been
problematic for me I can't quite wrap my
head around the cross District bullying
especially when it comes to the use of
cell phones
and whatever devices we that the kids
have access to and i would support the
motion for interim study should it come
up at a later
moment further discussion representative
McDonald again with respect for my
friend and colleague I'd have to
disagree I think it is unfortunate that
the particular incident occurred that
was presented to US during testimony and
we have also received testimony that if
a bill like this had been ratified prior
that it could have caused less of a
traumatic experience on The Afflicted
student and family in terms of dealing
with the incident I'd also like to add
that it would be negligent of this
committee to assume that future
incidents of bullying even of the
magnitude are not to occur again and
this bill could be preventative in terms
of establishing a plan to really deal
with those cases so I think it's of the
utmost importance that we pass this bill
now as opposed to put in inrm study
because this could happen again further
discussion not see any uh Madam clerk
would you please call the A rooll and
the motion on the table is OTP for
1216 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative
leus
yes representative Ford yes
Representative beler no representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative
Noble
no representative
Pell
no Representative corello no
representative Miler
no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
Luna no representative Heath no
Representative wock no representative
Hall no Representative albon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad
yes uh 68 14 a okay do we have a
subsequent motion representative Miler
yeah I would move to uh interim study
this is there a
second motion made by represent mil
second by represent Damon motion is to
in room study 1216 further discussion no
sir thank you no okay
uh Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Coro yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell representative
Tanner yes representative luno
representative Heath representative wock
representative Hall representative albon
yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad uh
yes 20 A's zero
a yeah we'll put in
consent and we'll jump now to to the uh
up top back to the early Bill 1677
participation in
efas I believe we have an amendment back
okay
16 is that the one that you got oh
you're going down to the ones down below
the EFA down there yeah I'm sorry okay
we're going to jump back down to 1652
which is an EFA local don't have 77 yet
Contin to check
okay
okay this is a bill relative to
establishing a local education Freedom
account program we've dealt with this
bill several years
ago yeah it's
revisiting so um second the charm
good
luck who wants to put forward this
motion represent
cordelli yeah there was an okay okay
yeah
sorry
okay
unless they went the other way
do
yeah want make a motion on
that uh represent cordellia you
recognize for a motion uh thank you I
would like to move on to pass on the
amendment that's coming around number
I'm sorry I'd written it down on my
sheet got ahead of myself ought to pass
there a second I'll
second it okay repres belter M second
rent
cordelli uh thank you um I would like to
um move uh Amendment 0393 H to House
Bill
is there a
second represent beler again represent
cordelli uh this is a simple um
Amendment um that uh I discussed with
the um Prime sponsor um he had copied
some language from um an early EFA
Bill and um to be consistent with
current um state funded
efas um the repeal that is mentioned in
this
amendment uh repeals uh uh page six
lines 23 to 26 which uh indicates that
the um uh scholarship amount should be
recalculated uh
annually
is that the only change correct in the
amendment
okay so the uh amendment is open for
discussion not see any discussion on it
uh Madam clerk would you please call the
role on the amendment Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative luus yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner nope
Representative luno no representative
Heath no Representative wock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman
lad yes 10 y 10 days so we're back to
the original motion ought to pass ask uh
any further discussion on
that
Clark Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald representative Noble
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell representative
tenner no representative luno
representative Heath no representative
Woodcock representative Hall no
representative Balon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad yes 10 y 10 dayses mil
recognized for a motion move no moves
itl that's fine who wants to Second
represent Miler wants second it all
righty further discussion from represent
luno Noone and none I see from represent
Myer either and you're ready will call
the rooll this will be on
itl Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative Ford no Representative
beler no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no Representative corello no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balon yes resentative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10
n okay so I would assume that represent
luno makes that and The Minority Report
will be representa cordelli so to the
floor all right go to the floor moving
on let's see other we got
here yeah that's that just yeah okay the
other one
so we'll go back up to the early bills
and we'll look at
1677 relative to participation in the
education Freedom accounts based on
school or School District proficiency
scores
down way
minut
[Music]
sorry
all the
trees
okay no it was just more I was just
passing down more so if it's the same
that's why so just passing down the
extras Amendment so we
never did you guys identify person make
this
motion we don't have one yet move to p
I'll do both
okay okay so everybody should have that
Amendment so we're going to look to
represent cordelli for a motion on the
bill thank you I'd like to move on to
pass is there a
second represent beler seconds the
motion ought to pass made by represent
cordelli represent cordelli um do you
care to speak to your motion or uh offer
an amendment yes thank you um
uh I'll do both um uh I I I am agreement
with the um intent of the original Bill
uh I am not sure that the 49%
proficiency level is the right one so
therefore I am uh offering ought to pass
on Amendment
H is there a second second
represent Ford seconds the amendment
0389 H made by represent
cordelli represent
Celli you speak to it you did speak a
little bit to it um just a little bit
more okay um on the amendment um the
proficiency level um is
reduced uh so in order to
qualify um for an EFA under this
legislation uh the student would have to
be in the bottom
25% of proficiency levels in mathematics
reading or
science forur this
discussion represent luno sure thanks
very much so so in um in in moving this
forward and supporting in in your
support of the amendment would you um
would you also support um initiatives
that would um improve the uh
proficiency level in um in school
districts um I've tried to improve
reading proficiency levels in schools
yes represent
Tanner yeah I I'm a little bit confused
with the um uh bottom 25% Proficiency in
mathematics so you have a scale of one
to four on proficient on the assessment
and no number two on that is proficiency
so are you talking
about I don't know what you're talking
about whether you're talking about the
bottom
25% being in in the fourth category or
which is basic or are you talking about
not having 20 at least 25% in the
proficiency um if you look at the
dashboard I think um on this state
department website the I platform
by by platform database um you can get a
listing um of proficiency levels and so
um it's broken into the top 25 schools
bottom and the bottom 25% of
schools so you're talking about 25% of
schools not 25% of proficiency 25% of
schools in terms of their proficiency
levels but I don't know if that's what
this says but that's why it's kind of
confusing to
me
I I would say if you look at you're
talking about a school or School
District with an agre aggregate
performance level in the bottom
25% of proficiency and in either one of
those subject
areas yes we're not talking strictly
either math either we're talking the
whole nine yards reading language arts
and science
and it's the bottom quartile of terms of
proficiency that in if a district lays
within that then those students there
would be
eligible represent Kaden just a question
as to why we would ex exclude public
charter
schools
Oh I thought you
were representative Heath I don't have a
response to represent K's question I
have another comment to make gon Cas Kon
is there an answer to that question why
we were excluding public charter
schools uh in in terms of the amendment
I was just working off of the original
bill
um that doesn't answer the question yeah
represent Heath my comment is more uh
General in nature Over The Last 5 Years
our school districts our country has
gone through the worst
upheaval that we've seen in over 100
years um to put a bill in place like
this at a time where kids were out of
school we've seen kids leave school
we've seen come back to school we've
seen an increase on mental health issues
there have been the pandemic caused so
many different issues for so many
reasons I just don't think this is the
time or place do I believe we should
have equity for all kids absolutely do I
want to see my city of Manchester
performing at the average or above
absolutely but you know what when I hear
the stories and I listen to Educators
talk about what's been going on across
the country in in my state this just
it's not fair to do this to our
Educators our families it just would be
another nail in the coffin of public
education I want to respond to that
and we have seen and we're looking at
math scores we've seen this going on for
over a decade it's not a result of what
happened with the covid pandemic uh
we've had a slippage in that and that's
what we had the task force which was
headed by at that time Paul leather and
they came out saying this needs a lot a
lot of work and so mathematics has been
not we have not really always fared as
the way we should be refering with that
subject for many years not just result
of covid can I respond to that
yeah how often has the state of New
Hampshire provided funding for local
school Improvement when in our last
budget did you see money to go to the
department first of all we talked about
the Department of Education not having
any curriculum people we've talked about
the the levels of support in title one
yes there are levels of support coming
but we haven't seen teachers brought
together we haven't talked about these
issues no direct support has been
provided before we start penalizing I
think we should Define some steps that
we can provide equitable distribution of
our funding sources and help the school
districts we have public and public
schools and public charter schools to do
better in their work so I think we have
a lot of things we can do before all of
a sudden saying well anybody that scores
in the bottom proficiency now can go to
a different School District or we're
going to give you an EA to go someplace
else I I'm sorry I just I know that this
is personal for me because I've been an
educator all my life but what I've
experienced and watched over the years
this just
I just can't stand back and not say
anything about this because we have an
obligation to the students in our state
and I don't think this is a solution by
simply sending them someplace else thank
you very much for listen represent
cordelli and then representative beler
um thank you um uh I would agree with
representative lad in that um the test
scores um have not gone down just as a
results of the pandemic um as a matter
of fact uh um New Hampshire I've read is
one of the um leading States in terms of
learning loss recovery in the
nation um in addition in the last budget
that was mentioned um school funding was
increased by over 160 billion $160
million thank you um and
secondly
um um there is the Esser funds the
federal funds that have been provided
school districts I know just in my local
little school district with seven little
towns um they still haven't figured out
how they're going to spend $6 million in
phase three funds that are expiring to
the end of September so there is money
out there so um I'm I'm sorry there is
there has been money um provided um via
the budget and via the federal funds uh
to recover from learning loss um you
know we've had bills to to improve
literacy that have not passed um so uh I
think we have been doing our share to
try and um improve student
outcomes PR beler thank you Mr chair um
to the point I was brought up earlier as
far as chartered schools why they're
excluded I think a careful reading of
this will find that uh chartered school
students are not excluded but the
charter schools themselves are simply
excluded from the uh calculation for the
aggregate
um well that I don't have an answer to
but just wanted to clarify that um as
far as uh the the the intent of this
bill to get these uh students the
opportunity to leave a uh school that is
performing near the bottom I I I fully
agree with the idea of reforming schools
so that they're that they're producing
better outcomes um I'd like to see
schools doing that at the same time I I
can't I can't get on board with the idea
of leaving any student in the lurch in a
in a bottom performing School while the
school is working to improve itself I
believe we need to be able to walk and
chew publicum at the same time on this
one thank you represent
Mila thank you Mr chairman once again
we're faced with
a uh a bill that has no fiscal
note so we just basically open up the
budget y all
come and also there are no guidelines to
you're going to hear me that say that
time and time
again we've tried to provide those
timelines those who advocate for this
totally reject it at some point in time
folks this is going to get so
big that you're going to wonder who in
the hell is running the shop
here that alone with this this proposal
here whether it's 49% or
25% we just don't know what it's going
to
cost and I'm surprised that some of the
fiscal conservatives in this room are
going to allow this to happen when we
talk about funding kids to have meals
big issue about how what it costs no
question about it
here I wish it'd be a little
consistent uh just to inform you there
is a fiscal note attached to this bill
and that's what it says right
here but there is a fiscal note and you
said there was no fiscal
note give me a break will and it does it
does State the cost that we're spending
per pupil in it so do the
multiplication um so but I also want to
Echo where uh represent cordelli was
that we do have professional development
money we've been talk we talked about
that title 2 money for many times in
here and there's still excess to that in
in the department budget right now for
the schools yes represent luno thank you
very much so um just a couple of points
I'd like to make I think um you know the
discussion and the um and the the
amendment as as presented there's a
little bit of a slight of hand being
done because it's not saying a student
who is a member of the ADM you know
going to a school that's in the bottom
25% just says lives within the
boundaries of such school district and
uh we know that Manchester is one of
those districts where student outcomes
are significantly below State average
and that's not because of the kids in
Manchester it's not because the teachers
or the administrators in Manchester it's
just because Manchester is underfunded
by about $100 million and um and there's
certainly a lot of people who live in
the Manchester Geographic boundary that
attend uh private schools and this would
just further promote um uh the use of uh
voucher dollars State taxpayer money to
uh to to basically be tuition rebate
programs and um and which is which is
absolutely what we have seen with this
um uh with this program but um but you
know further I just want to want to
comment on um on you know just the just
the idea that that um that New Hampshire
you know students are somehow you know
performing at a subpar level because
they're not so any objective standards
and there are lots of them that point to
the strong outcomes that we're seeing uh
across the state u in terms of in in
terms of of student performance um and
to to suggest that uh that that this is
some sort of relief valve uh for that is
um is incorrect because what we don't
have any data to point to zero data to
point to is how how how student per how
students are students with vouchers are
performing and there every every every
time we have tried to put any sort of
assessment or accountability on this it
has been summarily rejected uh by it so
so I can't see how possibly how possibly
even if you even if we did believe that
um that this was going to be limited to
uh to students or directed to students
with uh with with uh with low
performance that they would do any
better at all with a voucher because
there is zero evidence to suggest that
further
discussion repres
leus now that this is devolved into a
funding argument I do want to
mention
that in the 1990s I
believe um when
the court system across the country
started
pushing heavily
for um
Equity
Etc they started demanding that states
provide more and more and more money
particularly in school districts which
were not performing as well as other
school districts and I believe it was
Kansas City but I'm not
positive they kept increasing and
increasing the amount of money until the
whole state was being money was being
collected to give to this one school
district that kept not improving their
results and they got to where they had
so much money they were trying to figure
out how to spend it they had done all
the standard small class sizes after
school hours Etc everything they could
think of everything that had been
published this the outcomes still were
not improving they had swimming pools
and tennis courts and whatever because
they'd already done all the things that
everybody had
suggested and ultimately the program was
discontinued the outcomes had actually
started to decline and not get better so
as long as we're saying just give more
money just give more money and the
schools will be better just give more
money and the schools would be better
obviously we need to be doing something
different than just giving more money
because we've tried that all across the
country that was one of the most
egregious examples but we have tried it
all across the country and just give
more money does not improve results we
have to do things differently and if you
took a scatter plot I mean if you took a
plot of the amount of money spent per
school district and the outcomes in the
school district it looks like a scatter
plan it looks like somebody threw sand
on it because there is no correlation
between money spent and outcomes okay
um we ought to be conscious of of our
time that we have here because we're
going to get this stuff done today and I
don't want to be here till
55:30 represent Tanner I just I have to
uh disagree with the last statement that
uh representative lake has made because
in the commission on school funding
there several charts that will point to
that fact and the other thing is that I
believe Kansas was a state that had to
close their schools in like March or
April because they didn't have enough
school funding to make it through the
rest of the
year one short comment Mr chair and my
request is that the Department of
Education come up with a plan to lead
the learning across the state of New
Hampshire for the purpose of increasing
assessment School
after that happens then I would
entertain something like well probably
not but if we want to be honest but do
not lie we have not seen anybody from
the state level leading the learning in
our local school districts thank you
very much I gson Woodcock thank you I'm
not going to stop top of the fing but I
I will talk about I the I find insulting
cand uh and I couldn't find any other
piece of legislation when I look inside
under the short title and it says
reforming negligent
schools I find that insulting to our
teachers to our administrators to our
parents everyone working in these
schools trying to improve student
achievement and I look at the sponsors
of the bill and I'm not
surprised I I want you to be very
careful when you're pointing arrows
there just telling the sponsor the bill
and the name I don't see any of the
bills here represent I could be wrong
I'm a young guy here in this this game I
don't see any other shot titles in any
Bill we've seen in the six year 11 here
like that thank
you okay Madam
clerk please call the
rooll vice chairman cordelli am yes the
am yes on the
amendment yes representative lus yes
representative Ford yes representative
vure yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Heath Representative wock no
representative Hall no Representative
abon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad yes 10 y 10 Nays back to
the main
motion the motion was OTP on the bill
1677 any further discussion Madam clerk
call the rooll please
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative bon no representative
casc
no representative Damon absolutely not
chairman lad yes 10 y 10 I have a motion
Mr represent Tanner I have a motion itl
this bill so the motion made by
represent Tanner to itl Second by
represent
Miler further discussion or just move
on okay when you're ready Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative Ford no representative
Ure no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
pel no Representative corello no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell representative tenner yes
representative luno representative Heath
yes representative wup yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10
days okay so repr Tanner you write the
one report and represent cortelli the
other
one okay the next bill which we got is
1419 I see an amendment
here killer yes go ahead and take that a
five minute
break
no that's
right let's go
around me yeah they're taking a break
we're taking a break right
now
okay we're back in business I just took
it I
was so we're we're on H
1419 and I recognize representative
cordelli for a motion uh thank you Mr
chairman uh I would like to move a to
pass on House Bill
1419 is there a second to the motion
ought to pass
represent Noble makes that
motion repres Cordell you recognized
thank you um
we've talked about this quite a bit
during the uh during the hearing um this
is something that uh has been in works
for the past year um it was tabled last
year
um the important things are that we um
removed K12 education from the
exemption uh under criminal statutes uh
for uh obscene
materials um and um it is not expected
that there
will in any foreseeable future be any
criminal um uh charges along those lines
um there is a process a minimum process
laid out um for uh parents to appeal um
uh in reference to materials that they
think are uh inappropriate um in the
school um and thirdly um
if um if the
district uh does say that or the state
board says that materials should be
moved um or not made available to
certain age groups and the school does
not do it then there is a um complaint
civil complaint process that is uh
included in the bill um and all of this
has been worked on um with the attorney
general um definitions and
um definition of what's harmful to
minors um was all taken from uh um
Supreme Court cases um primarily uh
Ginsburg ver New York versus
Ginsburg and um I think that it's uh
really in um hopefully there are not
many um instances where um parents will
have to go to um the schools to complain
about materials I know it has happened
in um a number number of communities in
New Hampshire and I think there has to
be uh remedies available to uh to all
parents um when this situation
occurs represent Noble do you have
anything to add to
this um I just a little bit I I agree
with everything representative cordelli
said um I think the appeal process is
really important for
parents um there's
been a lot of books brought up over the
last couple years and each time I see a
new one it is more disturbing than the
previous one I've
seen most of which I couldn't even read
here because it puts the New Hampshire
House of Representatives YouTube channel
at
risk but I'd like to share with you
um one that doesn't have any naughty
words but um is disturbing
nonetheless this is in a book that's
called let's talk about
it um it's in the conquered High School
library and one of the pages says a
great place to research fantasies and
Kinks safely is on the
internet the online world is also choca
block full of pornography professionals
and amateurs alike sharing their sexy
Adventures
online but depending on your age and
where you found it porn can also be
unethical or illegal to watch so do your
research look up interviews with your
favorite porn performers go to the sites
they recommend and pay for your
porn in another illustration there's one
um kid that says huh sometimes I worry I
watch too much porn you know yeah I know
that worry but there's nothing wrong
with enjoying some porn it's a fun
sugary
treat
you know these are things that we should
be discouraging for miners in our Public
Schools here's something else that
promotes naked selfies if you're lucky
enough to be on the receiving end of a
requested dirty picture don't go sharing
or spreading that photo without
permission before you start sending your
naughty masterpieces around the world
take some time to get friendly with
photo editing software Ware or
apps sending or getting a wanted Saucy
something from a partner can be the
highlight of your day this is not
appropriate for Miners and I have yet to
find the limit of what
people will be
will find unacceptable in our Public
School libraries every time I bring
something up it gets shut down and I'm a
book banner and that's all I have to say
further disc discussion represent
Cordell thank you Mr
chair our children are supposed to go to
school to learn what in God's name are
they learning from that
garbage represent
Tanner thank you I think we heard just
this past week a very
thoughtful well researched
bill that speaks to Community
Values in how to actually go through a
process that brings the community
together in a reasonable way to
address materials that parents feel are
unwelcomed in in the school library this
bill on the other
hand slams down a hammer opens the door
to book Banning it
um removes the
obscenity restrictions from this the
criminal law law because the criminal
law talks about Community
standards we know that there are groups
in culture wars throughout the United
States and in New Hampshire that will
bring in a folder to a school of a
number of books tens of books that they
want banned out of the library they
haven't even read them they don't know
the context of them um it puts the
school in a
process that they have to remove the
books and then uh go through a whole
process that's that's usually very
contentious and doesn't speak to
Community Values and what the schools
are actually trying to do um libraries I
think uh we've heard are the windows to
the world it's the way kids can explore
the world learn new
experiences um I went to
um a talk the a couple months ago by
Jody Pico she's the most banned book
author
in the United States and I don't know if
anybody else here reads Jody Pico but I
do I've read her for a long long time
she has the problem is for her is that
she tries to approach very controversial
issues but as she approaches those
issues through her characters she tells
the story from many many sides of the
story when I was in school people tried
to ban um One Flew Over no uh tequilla
mocking bber and it was one of my
favorite books and um you know when you
start getting picky about little things
uh you know you can you can just set
everything into total chaos um we're not
a country that bans books we're not a
state that bans books um but we are a
state that uses reasonable processes to
involve parents in the school um and as
I said I think the the bill that we
heard this past week meets those needs
and we don't need this
bill further discussion represent
leus I'm still trying to figure out
how the book that she was referring to
meets Community standards
when it was just a few years ago schools
were spending a lot of time explaining
why students shouldn't be sending nudies
over the internet to their boyfriends or
girlfriends why you know um I have I
know numerous couples who have been
working for the last 20 30 or more years
dealing with the problems that come from
addiction to porn and the effect that
that's having on married couples
and I
just I guess I just don't get how our
community has come to the point where in
this short period of time we've gone
from not sharing nudies to oh here's how
you do it and it's a really good thing
and not becoming addicted to porn and
all the reasons why not to to oh this is
this is the best porn that you can watch
let's do
this how did we get here and why is this
acceptable and in our
schools through the discussion represent
B bony uh thank you um I just want to
talk a little bit about personal story
uh one of the books is on the one of the
Bands is a book that I presented to my
own kids it's called It's Perfectly
Normal it's a book that talks about sex
education for elementary children and I
for the life of me it's perfectly
acceptable for for me to give that to my
children and that's my choice it's if
it's available in a library book and you
don't want to take it out for your kids
that's fine um but I don't think that we
should be in the business of dictating
what our school districts do there are
policies in place and if those districts
don't have policies there's another bill
that's coming through that mandates that
schools establish those policies and I
think that if we go down and try to
Define prevailing standards and use
other vague
definitions um it's it's not fair it's
just not fair to the other people that
might think that it's okay and there
might be a specific reason why that book
is important to that child and we
certainly shouldn't be cherry-picking
phrases out of books without looking at
them in their entirety and that is up to
our professionals and our schools to do
that and there are processes in place
but the final decision should rest
within our school
boards represent
Noble what I just read to you is not
cherry-picking and this defense of this
sexually explicit material is such a
poor reflection on public
schools
thank
you representative Celli uh thank you a
couple of things um uh I agree that um
libraries can be a window to the
world
um but the world isn't always a safe
place there is evil in the world also um
certainly wouldn't say that the internet
um is uh
a safe place all the time for minors um
and in terms of um we heard in the
hearing and again today about Community
standard um let me just go back to that
because the original case with obscenity
was Miller versus
California and in that case um Mr Miller
wanted obscenity defined on a national
basis
the and let me quote the trial court
instructed the jury to evaluate the
materials by contemporary Community
standards of
California it was a State Community
standard that they Court ruled on or
ruled for not as opposed to a National
Standard so that's that's what we're
talking about um and uh we're not just
talking about pornography you know I've
seen materials I've got one here that
someone gave me pictures of of kids
cutting
themselves you know so it's just not
pornography there's other um dangerous I
think materials uh being made available
um in some libraries in some school
libraries um we've talked about suicide
how many times have we talked about
child suicide and mental health what are
we doing if we're presenting materials
to them with um information and stories
about kids cutting themselves and
committing suicide are we helping a
child in that regard I don't think
so represent McDonald thank you Mr chair
moments ago the concept of local control
was brought up and I'd like to focus on
that for a
bit I was approached on about this bill
by a constituent who is a single father
of two School AG childrens within our
school district and our school district
does have these policies in place like
many across the state and a concerned
parent approached the school board about
a particular
book and the school district was not
able to help in that case despite having
these policies on the books and in this
particular incident would have benefited
from a directive from the state I have
shared with you his testimony both in
paper and he shared it with all of you
via email I'd encourage you to take a
look at it his name is Kevin gag
and on that instance we love our public
schools and this isn't any way to be
condescending towards them or anything
negative just even schools with these
policies in place could benefit from the
directive from the state and that's all
I really have to say thank you thank you
very much representative petno then
representative
cascaden I'm just curious if anybody
could point to the specific section of
the test that or this section of the
test
I feel like I'm taking a test um the
section of this bill that
um states that books are actually being
banned by this proposed
legislation well um thank you I actually
can't answer her question directly
because I don't think it's in there
because this is not a bill about book
Banning book Banning is being
misunderstood um by the definition of
how some people think about book Manning
the um you know any Library can only
hold a finite number of books there are
selection processes but it comes to the
point where you know the only library
that possibly wouldn't be accused of
book Banning would have to have every
single book ever published book Banning
as I in the hearing you know people kept
saying book Banning book Banning book
Banning which is kind of a trigger term
for me um because it's so misunderstood
it means nobody can can access that book
anywhere you go to jail if you read it
it isn't published that's book Banning
this is just selecting materials and
this bill gives clear guidelines as to
what materials would you know certainly
what representative Noble read would
meet the criteria of the Miller test and
those three criteria so now this bill is
not at all about book Banning represent
cascaden thank you Mr chair I just uh
could you explain to me why RSA 571 in
the criminal codes right exposing miners
to harmful materials and then opse
matter is 650 colon
2 if those laws are on the
books why aren't there charges
filed um oh why isn't this why do we
need this policy if it's against the law
according to these criminal codes
can who's got can you explain that
represent cordelli well in terms of 650
um that's the criminal code
and education right now is
exempt education period is exempt from
the obscenity
statutes this bill changed it so that um
uh K12 is no longer exempt but higher
education remains exempt from the OB
obscenity statutes because for the most
part we're talking about
adults represent
Tanner just that um if a book is banned
if a book is taken out of a library that
I use if it's taken out of a school
library where my kid is a student and I
don't have access to that
book that book is banned and this is all
about banning books is about going
through and seeing books that you don't
like or that that you don't think is
appropriate for other people just like
uh representative balbon said why should
you be able to ban books from somebody
else in the
community that's that unless you have a
community
consensus representative bone um yes I
was just going to point out um to
representative Tanner's point and
representative peternell asked where
does it say baned it does actually on
this on page three uh talks about
materials being removed or restriction
restricted and that that's a ban
I want to just inform everybody that um
just let my wife's a librarian and they
have in this day in library loan so just
because a book is not available at one
place doesn't mean you're Bann from
using that book you can request from
your librarian to have that book maybe
brought up from another Library
elsewhere in the
state represent Bon you're talking about
children's libraries and you're you're
have a pretty high expectation that
those children are going to know that
they're going to access or request an
into Library librarian in a public
school library in fact in Pont the
public library is across the street from
the school and the school kids come
across she's a certified teacher and if
there's a book that they're looking at
then it's gone done through inner
Library loan and adults come in there
too and the teachers come in there and
Order books so it you know it's we have
many of our libraries in the North
Country uh get support from their town
library too and that helps us with a
finance Point too and Staffing going
further with
questions yes represent whitcock thank
you thank you chairman just a
clarification or emphasis on the
information that uh represent cordelli
when he was talking about the Miller
case Supreme Court ruling that was
decades upon decades upon decades ago
on Community Values Community standards
I'm not not questioning what you're
saying GL you're saying you understand
it was decades upon decades ago decades
ago thank
you represent Damon thank you Mr
chair I want to note that it is not only
books that would be limited if this bill
were to
pass and I would ask people to think
about the impact of this on health
education and on art
education for an example I would
particularly think some folks might be
aware of a famous old painting if I'm
correct it's from the mid
1600s it's called The Three
Graces it depicts three nude women
standing
outside two with their back to the
Observer one face
forward it is one of the most famous
paintings in art history and it was used
is
used to show that different sized bodies
were respected and appreciated in other
times these are Buxom women is how I
would describe
them I can't imagine that we want to
create a world where our students cannot
access art that shows all different
kinds of
bodies and respects that it's beautiful
it's not
porn but as I read this bill and think
about that art and many other pieces of
that era in art I don't think we could
introduce our students to them and I
think that's wrong number three okay
okay before I take any more for we we
have some Amendment also for this
um um yeah yeah I I'm
just I'm getting a hint where this
thing's going so um represent leus and
then we're going to try to move on
here with regard to to what you said I I
um having studied plenty of Art and art
history and done my history through ART
um I do want to point out that in the
bill for the purposes of this
subdivision material is harmful to
minors when the material lacks serious
literary scientific medical artistic or
political value so those things would
not fall under this because they do not
lack artistic or medical Etc subject to
interpretation okay are there any
amendments in this just one you
introduced it yet no why don't you go
ahead and do that uh thank you uh Mr
chairman I I think maybe we can get to
the amendment at this point um it is and
I'd like to offer uh ought to pass on
Amendment
0391 H which I hope everybody has at
this
point so you're putting that forward is
there a second all second represent
Noble second that so we have an
amendment before us 03
91h uh that's
2419 presented by representative cord
cordelli and second by representative
Noble representa cordelli uh thank you
it's um
Amendment um it modifies U page two of
the original Amendment which had um four
uh definitions for material that is
harmful to minors um three were taken
from the Miller versus
California um Supreme Court ruling as to
what is harmful to
minors um I guess I tried to pay play
Supreme Court Justice and added a fourth
um which is probably not NE necessary um
I don't think I'd make a very good
Supreme Court
justice so it deletes at number four it
deletes number four yet
okay uh represent Noble do you have as
makeer the second of the motion nothing
further thank you are there is there any
further
discussion uh Madam clerk with any
please call the role on the
amendment Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative luus yes representative
for
yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pel yes representative
Coro yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative luno
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative bon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad
yes t
okay we're back to the main motion now
which is ought to pass on uh on the bill
1419 any further discussion not seeing
any
uh Madam clerk would you please call the
role Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative elure yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Coro yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Luna no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative bon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad
yes 10 y 10 days motion yes represent
Miler is so who repres uh motion made by
representative milers second by
representative Damon itl is the motion
further
discussion okay Vice chairman cordelli
no Representative leus no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no Representative
corello no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes yes
representative Tanner yes representative
lunell representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock representative
Hall yes representative Bel yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman
lad
no good okay I'm
sorry okay so representative Bon is
writing that report and and who's doing
the represent cordelli
okay uh we have a another early bill on
the docket here it's
1402 1402 deals with the high school
proficiency
exam the
represent leus do you have a motion I
would like to move OTP on 1402 is there
a
second okay we have a motion made by
representative leus and second by
representative dry uh representative
leus would you like to speak to your
motion yes yes I would like to introduce
an amendment amendment number
0392 H
is there a second to the
amendment represent Ford seconds
Amendment uh for 1402 that's 0392 and a
motion was made by represent leus
represent
leus yes originally the bill had two
parts to it one which allowed a student
to stay in the
school and continue taking courses that
was directed at somebody who wanted to
start like the
um violin player who was phenomenal and
wanted to get to work performing with an
a an orchestra but still wanted to take
a few courses at the high school but
there is a way that that can be done if
they become a homeschool student and if
the parent doesn't get in trouble for
not
teaching uh the required courses and
allowing their student to go ahead and
spend their day with the orchestra that
student could then go
to the um like
the CTE Center and take a business
course um so I took that out and all
this covers is the student who knows the
stuff and just wants to be done with
school with high with high school or
School in general so they can get on
with the things that they want to do
with their life thank you very much oh
you're done well no I was just going to
say I found it very interesting when I
was um in the hallway after introducing
this bill and there were some guys
talking who were waiting to testify in
another bill and one of them was like oh
my goodness I would have loved to have
this when I was in school so I didn't
have to stay in prison and he used that
same term that the guy who came in and
testified who know I did not know it was
going to be there and and testify um
that is the feeling of a certain portion
whether or not I loved school I wanted
to keep going and going and going okay
let's let's stick to this bill please
yep further discussion on the
amendment yes represent Woodcock thank
you Le can you explain about the the
paying for the
exam first out the educational trust
fund and second for the the not
successful student I don't understand
the paying for the
exam the idea for that was I did not
want any student from a poor family to
be denied this right because they
couldn't um or denied this opportunity I
should say because they couldn't pay for
it and it will save the this the state a
fair amount of money $4,000 and some
dollar every year um if they do stop
going to school so it seemed reasonable
that the state could pay that small
amount for the exam however I didn't
want kids just taking advantage of that
whether they had no hope or chance of
passing and just keep you know taking
the exam so the idea was to limit it to
the first time to one time so that they
wouldn't take it unless they were pretty
sure they can pass it PA Mr sheer please
yes I I still understand the money for
the exam who's who's paying whom how
much do it cost why would they have to
pay for an exam because the exam is
probably going to be like the highet or
the GED and said the commissioner is
going to do it
WR I said the commissioner of the
Department of Education shall choose and
the commissioner may choose the highet
and the highet does have an age
exemption that can be made so
that any age could take it thank you
thank you chair further further
discussion represent Pell yes thank you
very much um I remember I don't know how
long ago it was but when they were
changing the age of compulsory
attendance from 16 to 18
and I was I remember thinking what are
they going to do with these students
from 16 to 18 maybe they were struggling
already to keep them in school and now
they have to stay in school and you you
know no matter what we do for some
people I still think school doesn't
always fit everybody and that man that
came in and
testified um he I went out in the
hallway afterwards and I said to him
thank you for testifying you are exactly
the person who I thought of when I
agreed to co-sponsor this legislation so
even if it only helps one person I don't
expect that a lot of people are ever a
lot of students are actually going to
utilize this but if it gives some
struggling students a way out then I'm
in support of this
bill further
discussion represent Hall how young
what's the youngest a kid could be in
this there's no age there's no age limit
on this one five years old could just
say I'm not going school don't have to
go to school they would have to pass the
high test which is recognized as the
high school equivalency which lots of
kids take rather than getting a diploma
like a good portion of the homeschool
kids and other kids both of all of my
kids took geds because they left school
early further discussion thank you not
seeing any so we have uh an amendment on
the before us here uh it's it's uh for
1402 it's 0392 if H if there's no
further
discussion we'll move forward with a
vote on that Amendment Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Heath no Representative wock no
representative Hall no Representative
albon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
[Applause]
yeah can we have a caucus yeah that's
what we're just discussing up here there
will be a caucus for about five minut
this
here
e
I would like to withdraw my OTP
motion
so
that I'd like to recognize you thank you
Mr chair at this point in time I
recommend interim
study yes thank you I know I speak for
several members of the committee when I
say that this bill as is although well-
intended I could not vote for there are
several concerns such as
the parental consent is not mentioned
within this bill and I believe that that
is a mistake as well as students after
taking this test they're away from
compulsory attendance but they would
still be able to attend school and there
could be problems with that and to
students
who are not willing or not requesting to
continue school because they'd like to
seek higher education I'd recommend the
programs we have in place such as our
dual conr current current enrollment
courses excuse me so at this time I
think interim study is a better motion
so that this bill could be worked on and
perhaps improved and that's all I have
to say thank you thank you very much
further
discussion okay yes represent mil yeah
thank you uh Mr chair I appreciate the
effort to U deal with this bill in an
affirmative fashion before I before I
vote on uh interim study though I would
like to ask former Deputy Commissioner
of Education Mary Heath to address the
issue of what's already available for
students who are 16 years or older who
want to leave school early if I may Mr
chair I'd like to have Mary address this
represent Heath if art Ellison were here
he could give you a better detailed
summary than I but um it is possible now
um to gain permission if a student is
under the age of 18 um and at least 16
to request permission from the
Department of Ed to take the GED or
equivalent test um and attain a a
diploma now the diploma does not come
from the school district it comes it
would be um a a document saying that
they had passed a test and that they
have uh achieved equivalency to high
school further
discussion represent Tanner so one of
the main differences in in what we see
in this bill and what you're saying is
that in this bill they actually get a
diploma from the high school that that
they decide they don't want to go to is
that correct or the state they could
they could get it just says they may and
if the state if the district says no
then it's from the
state and this excuse me and a state has
a
diploma the state the state can do that
yes
[Music]
any further
discussion okay Madam clerk would you
please call the rooll we are the motion
is interim study for for the bill vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus yes representative Ford yes
representative elure yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative
Tanner yes representative luno yes
representative Heath representative wock
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 20 y Zer n uh I get to go home in
the light tonight
maybe consent right pardon me is that on
consent
okay so we we have now I think addressed
all those early bills which we had a top
I hope y okay wonderful that's our
primary goal for today um is there
anything else on there that um down
below I would like to do the ID cards
but for eating disorders but I don't
think we have the amendment for
that yes
message
she asking think the amendment's not
clear
said
they
oh read what I said and see if I'm
misinterpreting but I don't think the
last
section well we're having it there's a
real change going on across the street
right now all new and and there are some
bad references here and we've sent them
a few amendments today
unfortunate if if if that amendment's
not ready I think we're ready to call it
a
day uh could we
what 15 16 yeah sure let's do that
because I think we can
make well let's see what the decision is
on the amendment the eating disorder
Bill if not we'll do 1516
we have some folks that have to clear
house here around 4:00 so we got about
15 minutes
here well if if it's not available let's
shoot for 1516 right
now
okay 1516 ail uh Rel to enrollment in
public schools by children of School
District employees I think we've gone
over that I think you all know what it's
about
um wasn't here when we had that caucus
who is going to make that motion
represent
dry okay okay good let's let's let's
push forward
OTP I make a motion ought to pass is
there a second second okay motion made
by representative uh dry and second by
representative cordelli uh
representative dry I'd like to make a
motion to accept the amendment it's 2024
d316 H and you all would have gotten one
of those yesterday on your desk oh yeah
that was a long time
ago basically
basically it rearranges
thing I left all my Amendment stuff in
the other room is is do you have a
copy
yeah can you walk us through the changes
in the amendment please yeah the changes
aren't
um uh content it's more of clarification
because a lot of the
the things that this is in an open
enrollment section and a lot of the
steps are the same as open enrollment so
the original Bill tried to kind of just
insert those there it made it very
unclear um whether we were talking about
Open Enrollment or talking about
something else and so the idea was to
bring the things that have to do with um
children of School Employees into
separate sections therefore that's why
it's uh Roman 3- a and Roman numeral 9-
a and Roman numeral 1- a so that it
separates it out in that chapter of law
there already is a section that's
similar to that that's on military
personnel so it it breaks that out of
the Open Enrollment section too so it's
there's a precedent for doing that I
think this brings it all in line with
that chapter of law the way that it's
written are there any questions
or discussion on that yes represent
um as I look at um for any for line
17 um the cost of any will be by payroll
deduction makes me chuckle because I
think our Paras in our school district
have to pay the I mean there been a
situation they had to pay the school
district just to get the health
insurance so I don't think it's coming
out of payroll you know what I mean like
they didn't make enough money even they
just barely covered their health
insurance that's why it's the or yeah
yeah but I just want to make that
statement but also so um this is
typically contractual whether it's a
Paris or whether it's the teacher Union
I mean this is something you negotiate
on whether you can um like our
administrators their kids can go to
school and Bowl but we could not do it
we couldn't even to wish our kids in but
it was a contractual thing this is
negotiated so that's all right and this
even it's the playing field throughout
the
state further discussion
from the from the Schoolboard
perspective this may um take a
negotiated item off the
plate that that's just the consequences
of that what may do but it also would
though on the other side of the coin
have certainly help the teacher who has
their Child Left Behind in their
resident community and they're working
next door or down the road
ways and they're trying to figure out
what to do with the child you know
because they can't get home to get and
where there is a teacher shortage going
on so you're sort of in between fa
places
here represent Damon
so just to make sure I'm understanding
this when it says in line five that
non-resident employees of the school
district May enroll their children in
the school district that does not sound
to me like the school district is
obligated to accept them
was that am I reading that
right ref
try actually the what it's means is that
there there are they can try they can do
that but the school has the option to
say no there's not adequate space or we
need additional staff or classrooms need
to be
added so if there was
space and nothing has to be
changed could they still say no
uh no they can't this is the the
emphasis is on but it's the impetus is
on the side of the parent yeah this like
not you don't have to do this this is
enabling legislation and I just want to
say that for recruiting and retention
this would be a nice piece um to offer
people and and our weather in the last
two weeks has just only um been a good
example of why you would love to have
families on the same educational
schedule if you could possibly do that
now I've got another question and it's
kind of just digging down as my mind's
going you're in a k through6 school and
your school district tuitions these kids
for grades 7 through 12 to other
receiving
districts
um how's that going to work in terms of
this this law right
here I believe School Board have to
approve or um you go to the the school
that you get into you get to finish yeah
if for example if you go to the school
that the school resending schools has a
contract as a receiving school then
they'll obviously pay that
tuition uh however if you're going to
another District that they don't have a
contract with how's that going to
work that's a really good question um I
think that's maybe a matter of the
policy of the
school because not every school is going
to have that situation
or this policy of the district well I'm
saying does the sending school district
have to pay that extra $244,000 instead
of the $20,000 load for the district
that they don't have the contract with
I'm going to who pays that I'm going to
refer again it's it's the parents are
Guardian to be um as per District policy
so it's going to vary from District to
District
% so would we I'm I'm sorry but so then
we just passed legislation last year
where the parent can pay the difference
is that what would happen is that in
effect now I believe so yes so yeah that
was part of the Bridgewater Bill no I
would assume be the case yeah
it's further chair yeah yeah I I've sort
of got some some um I think to our
concerns about this so looking at 194
deol and 2 and and as representative dry
said that is the chapter on open
enrollment um for example in the first
part of that chapter under definitions
it talks about it defines sending
district and it defines receiving
District so receiving District means the
school district which the pupil is sent
to attend an open open enrollment School
resident District means the school
district in which the student resides
sending District means the school
district in which the pupil
resides
um receiving District means the school
district which the pupil is sent to
attend an open enrollment school so is
that what's meant in in the the
amendment in section two under
9A what line
on 12 yeah you've got sending and
receiving district and uh yeah lines 12
and 13 essentially
so I would think so yeah so this is
intended only to apply to open
enrollment no no this is an ex it is
like an open enrollment but it is not
exactly as an open enrollment so the o
Open Enrollment as it's defined here is
is a school district that might have
different schools that serve different
parts of the community or different
parts of the district open rollment is a
vote that school districts take right
but I'm just saying as it's as it's
defined in here though means any public
school um in addition to providing ed
Service pupils residing within its
attendance area or
District choose to accept pupils from
other attendance areas
within its district oh and from outside
the district okay right so it's open to
any yeah any open enrollment you're
trying to you're trying to capture those
kids to
help the operational cost of that that
District that open enrollment school
right right well you're
you but which this would do as well and
would cut down on substitute time
because you wouldn't have
um parents having to teachers having to
stay home because their kids school
district was closed due to
weather right in many cases I mean I
think as as as chair lad said that's a
negotiated item in collective bargaining
agreements and and it is in a lot of
districts um um you know I I I I I
certainly I think from the school boards
from my perspective having been on a
school board I wouldn't want lose this
as a as a negotiating item and and I
don't want to I don't want to you know
sort of imply hearsay on on the um the
uh faculty Representatives but in
speaking with Mr Hawkins he said no
we're not we're not looking for this so
I I I I'm not quite sure what the what
the you know what the interest is uh
behind this I think it's in a very
strange section of the of the law
despite the
breakouts um
um so could I do a point of order too
please what's your point of order um if
the amendment is
0316 it's submitted by representative C
from AAC 26 who's not on this
committee I I yep go ahead no I believe
as long as it's submitted by a Committee
Member it's fine
yeah the rule in that is that a
Committee Member can introduce an
amendment such as this that some other
person in the house if it's a senate uh
we can't do it because it has to have a
representative in the in general court
on the amendment we have one right there
I yeah I thought it you had to you had
to be your name had to be on the
amendment here no no sorry thank you
clarification lot of rules aren't there
yeah
yeah yes representative uh Heath you're
red lights on that yes um please I just
a question so in a scenario let's say
for instance um I'm a teacher in Bedford
and um my kids currently go to school in
Manchester but because I'm a teacher in
Bedford I want my kids to be in Bedford
with me so um I would pay the tuition at
the full 80% of what the average tuition
is I'm just not clear on what is the
responsibility of the teacher in terms
of um cost and
secondly when I was an assistant
superintendent we often had requests
from staff members to have the children
go to the school district where they
were working and it was always up to the
school board to decide and in most
circumstances the school board did not
approve unless the family was willing to
pay the full tuition amount the full
cost of what it would cost for the child
to go there so I guess that's a whole
bunch of
questions it's a very complex issue when
you start
mixing kids and employees and and who's
who makes the ultimate decisions and are
we forced to um and the contractual
issues so it's just there's a lot I
think
per Dr you had your hand up thank you I
think that's why we put it under the
school district policy because so many
districts are there remember this is
enabling legislation if this is honorous
for family they just don't have to take
that policy and to address Mr L
representative luno I would I'd like to
show you on page 637 in uh Deon 2 and
it's Roman numeral 11 this is about
military connected students
and it goes on to say this is to Define
them as children of full-time active
duty um military personnel and it says
they shall be eligible for admission to
the school district of their choice it
doesn't give anything about an open
enrollment it doesn't give anything
about that all just defines what a
military person is and that's why we
felt that this was a place to put
another exception the students who are
um children of uh staff and teachers in
a school
district just to respond to that Mr
chair so so you know I I'm I'm not
suggesting that that the statutes are
perfect um in any way but but I I don't
think continuing to
misplace language or or you know or
perpetuate that uh style is necessarily
a good thing for clarity um you know but
but I I would offer that that I I first
I want to respond that it's it's not
enable enabling legislation something
that enables a district to do something
this actually requires the district to
comply so it's the opposite of enabling
legislation yes it's the choice of the
family to to whether or not they want to
send their student to that to um have
that student go to the district that the
staff member faculty or staff member is
that but this is an enabling legislation
the district has to comply with that
secondly
and it it it occurred to me that that
there could be some you know impact with
respect to nhiaa and in inter Scholastic
um Athletics because there there there
are situations where where students who
live in one District want to play ball
let's say in another district and so um
so um so it's been made clear that even
though some districts do tuition in
students that you can't do so
based on uh based on simply an an
athletic interest in that and I don't
know what the law is on that but but you
know I remember hearing about this years
and years ago so so so now this this
would allow a family member to take
employment at such a district and um and
and bring their child along possibly for
an athletic interest um as opposed to
something that was approved by the
voters you know colle a bargaining
agreement or something like that so so I
I have a lot of concerns about um about
this language represent uh Damon thank
you so I have a
question there are school districts that
I guess would be open enrollment schools
that they do take in tuition students
for instance
sunap but they interview and select who
they will take
in so if I'm a Snape teacher and I live
in Newport and I want my child to go to
school in
sopee assuming that there is
space not don't need additional staff
and classrooms as the amendment
says what happens with that interview
process can sunap or whatever similar
District still pick and choose who can
go or if you're the child of an employee
are you
automatically
that's that's a a real issue too that's
over in sunap has that strange agreement
where they're going to choose which kids
come in from you're NE the woods lemster
Goan yeah lemster Goan cord anywhere and
actually something is not unique anymore
newport's adopted the same thing well
only because the anchor school is
Newport there isn't an well it it used
to be right and so it it's it gets a
very convoluted comp I can tell you
though on the athletic
side when I was up north the schools
around me were doing anything they could
to get a hold of my two
daughters one was the state champion in
in a and and indoor and outdoor track up
there they all wanted that and the other
one was bass point guard they wanted her
so the the the and I refused to go but
the thing is that this is an issue
and we've had it occur with the you know
hockey and things like that they load up
one school and and principles are pretty
smart at that you know you look around I
want the winning team and and you can
get it very quickly just like that but
NHA tried to clamp down on that but the
way it used to be was a wide open Turf
represent Woodcock you have to sit out
by C thank you CH I have two one comment
or one question I want to make sure I'm
understanding this um and the financial
piece uh um if I understand this
correctly on line 23 and 24 in the
original bill it said the school uh
sunding school pay no less than 80% and
the rest is paid for by the the parent
20% is that how I understand
that yeah yeah so if that's the case
what happens if the 80% in that sending
School
District um is a lot less than the
receiving School District well that's
align with the question I asked at the
very beginning if especially if you're
tuing them out from a school that's
doesn't have those grade levels yeah let
say something something is like $18
$18,000 versus 26,000 yeah that's the
first one the second initi me the second
one is this is I know chairman you
mentioned that this is part of the could
be part of the teacher shortage uh
retention issue however this is all
staff all staff custodians secretaries
parking water tenants this is all all
staff so this could be a huge number of
folks going there and not just teacher
recruitment yeah okay make a comment
that's all that's right represent thank
you thank you um I just want to say if
they wanted their daughters they' have
to hire you so I'm just going to say
that would have to been part of the
bargain um but
I five time screw to God yeah there you
go um this works in other parts of the
state I mean it's working in conal it's
working in other places they get around
this tuition thing they get around this
if it's a bargaining chip it's because
it works in places and I just want to
see it work in the rest of the state
there are ways around it I know that
they're working on it otherwise it
wouldn't
exist further questions perap
I thank just just as an aside we've
talked about the athletic teams but I
would also from an academic standpoint
there may be somebody has a real good
math team that would like to have a good
math student to so I'm going to just
throw in the issue of the academics as
well as the Athletics I I really believe
this is a local issue I mean we' we
we've bounced around the ideas here and
I'm going to be voting against this
because I think if the local wants to do
this they already have the prerogative
to do it they can negotiate it um and
not that I want to give up any kind of a
perk for management but if you were to
do this it does take away that perk for
management and as a Union Advocate uh I
would be concerned I'd be delighted
because that means I don't have to give
something up to get this yeah uh but um
I think this is clearly a local issue
and not withstanding the intent behind
it I I recognize that intent and
appreciate that but I do think that this
is something that the local school
boards and the the local organizations
and unions can work this out
themselves representa
leus well I'm confused about some of the
arguments because my understanding is
that we're trying to come up with ways
of
encouraging employment in schools
because we're short not just in teachers
but in AIDS and in
all all sorts of positions in schools
and we're trying to figure that out and
yet the argument is we don't want to
give up a bargaining position but I
thought we were bargaining to get things
for teachers and so if we're trying to
help teachers and trying to retain them
why do we have
to why can't we just give this to
teachers instead of I don't know I don't
understand I what it would be all
employes well all employees it says
staff
so repent Hall there are some unintended
consequences so I'm a l teacher and I
live between Franklin and Bo and I'm
going to go teach in BO because my kid
can go to B now and Franklin now has
lost another person you know there's one
thing on their salaries that they lose
people and now they going to lose people
because the kids are going to go to
school somewhere else so I think that
there are obviously the sports but I
think it's way more it just sounds like
a nightmare to me when I'm thinking of
the whole staff most teachers don't and
staff don't well staff I don't know what
I'll say teachers most teachers don't
live in the district where they teach so
I mean this is a huge population of
people that this covers I think it just
sounds like a nightmare for it's it's
great would every if I asked every
teacher and every staff member in the
school and say would you like to be able
to send your kid a lot of them would
probably say yeah yeah I think that's a
good thing but I think the whole
management just sounds like holy
Snokes there there was a question that I
had when this bill came in and I would
like to have an answer on it if there's
a teacher that has a handicapped
student that has severe handicapping
issues and requires special equipment
special room
Etc and and that that has occurred fact
I can remember Dean Menner and I talking
about this this goes back to the school
boards about 12 years
ago that
what's going to happen when that school
where the teacher is working and want
wants to bring in this very handicapped
child and the school does not have any
of those facilities who Bears the cost
because it says the child shall be able
to come Mr chair that was that was
cleared by by Miss fet yep she said that
she said she said that the resident
School District which I would assume is
where the child lives would be
responsible for for those sped Services
she very clear about that but also
remodeling the room so that child can
function in the receiving School Maybe
not maybe not I don't think we got a
total answer to that and that really
concerns me there's a lot of physical
therapy stuff that
requires devices from the roof mats the
whole nine yards and if you have a child
like that come in and if you're a small
school you're not going to be able to
afford
it so
there I think this has wonderful
intent and it used to be done between
superintendent working it out with each
other and there were these mutual
agreements but now it we're stepping up
a whole Notch here and there's all these
issues that we got to consider and I
don't know if it should be going forward
without those answers specific those
questions specifically answered and um
it's a cause and result these results I
don't know if we're going to be able to
clarify them today great great idea but
I don't
know yeah yeah the the U part about
special education is in the funding
section as Roman numeral 2 and
it's it already deals with special
education children with disabilities
that are they're going to modify the
building then that they're going to well
I guess maybe we should ask some of the
Stu the districts that that work on that
and see how they do it obviously it's
working it's done it works so I'm just
saying I can't specify every district
and everything that's coming up but if a
if it's a bargaining chip thing
obviously um districts think that this
can
work well there are some severe
handicapping conditions when the
receiving school doesn't have the staff
doesn't have the facility the
room and there's a whole lot of other i'
I've been involved with that sure but
you can't if they need additional sha
staff that's a way a district can say we
don't we're not equipped not equipped so
now you're rejecting a student because
of their
disability so then there law barking
down your back doesn't have adequate
staff this is opening up Pandora's Box
well you're coming up with a lot of lot
of questions that I'm sure that there
are answers for because it wouldn't be
offered if these were unanswerable
questions
represent cordelli I would just say it's
it's not only working in parts of New
Hampshire but it's working in many
states around the country as
well are there further questions on
this okay we have a motion on the floor
the motion was on the
amendment not seeing any further
discussion we'll have a par me
the it's the motion is on uh
0316 ought to pass ought to pass yeah
yeah the amendment on Amendment on the
amendment for the record who seconded
the amendment did did
someone I I think I dident
dry just both things okay I didn't F in
that spot
okay we good yeah Vice chairman C
cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pno yes representative
corello yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
tenner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no representative
woodw representative Hall no
representative bon no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad yes 10 y 10 n so we have uh
the main Motion in front of us and I'm
going to call Caucus for about five
minutes I do need have 4:30 I know it I
know
I will withdraw
it agree
for
yes um the motion is interum study on
House Bill 1516 Madam clerk I think
we're ready for the roll call Vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus yes representative Ford yes
representative elure yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pel yes representative corello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative
Tanner yes representative luno yes
representative
Heath representative he yes uh
representative wock yes representative
Hall representative abon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
20 y
z